Oh
my first big trip when I was little I
was almost 8 years old and my father and
I went to Denmark together one summer
for maybe two or three weeks and that
was my first big adventure overseas soon
after that way my family moved to
England for a year moved back to
Massachusetts then we moved to a
different house then we moved down to
Virginia we moved around a lot uh and we
traveled a lot California England Italy
France and when I was a teenager I was a
skateboarder and I had access to my
parents car so I spent a lot of time
driving all over Virginia southeastern
Virginia just pulling into a new town
looking around trying to figure out how
the town is organized and constructed
try looking for great place to the
skateboard but that taught me a lot
about how cities are organized where are
the sort of industrial warehouse loading
dock zones where we can find places to
skate where nobody will see us how do
you find cities that have great sort of
marble or granite plazas in the center
so I you know throughout my high school
years I was exploring and exploring and
exploring so yeah I've never really
never really stopped moving ever since I
was about seven years old
it's terrible when you're traveling on
your own and you get sick and you don't
speak the language it's terrible the
first time that happens and then you
deal with it and then the next time it
happens you say out yeah I know how to
deal with this and then it becomes
easier and then next time becomes even
easier all of these things build on each
other and you learn better how to travel
by dealing with the really awful stuff
that does happen to you a lot of the
time when you travel you stay in a bad
hotel you get sick you're alone you get
lost these are all pretty traumatic
things that can happen but by dealing
with them by learning how to get unlost
by learning how to talk to a doctor how
to go to a pharmacy and find the drugs
you need to get better it makes it so
much easier the next time each of these
things makes you a stronger person and a
stronger traveler and you know after a
few years of that you can go anywhere
anytime on your own with friends and be
happy and comfortable and enjoy yourself
in a way that you never used to be able
to
I've lived in New York now for 12 years
and that's that's the longest I've lived
really anywhere since yeah my whole life
I don't think I'd spent 12 years in any
one place as a child at all then I Love
New York it's a very easy place to live
for me because you can do pretty much
anything you want at any time of day or
night um there's no limits on on on the
kind of life that you lead but I guess I
could I could leave it I could I could
go somewhere else as long as I'm near an
international airport that would be
great my wife and I talked about moving
back to Taiwan where she's from maybe in
a few years when our daughter is ready
for school but yeah we don't know yet I
mean that's what my daughter is 16
months old so that's at least three or
four years in the future and that's just
I mean that's impossible to say what's
going to happen for years from now I
don't know what's gonna happen in June
uh no idea I no idea what's going to
happen in june and july july is like the
23rd century so yeah talk about the
future and I don't really know but New
York I love it I don't want to live
anywhere else but hey you know what I
could
honestly if I if I had to to leave New
York and go live somewhere else just
just live there and not use it as a base
for going to other places I could
probably go back to toe chi minh city
vietnam back to Saigon and spend quite a
bit of time there I loved it when I
lived there I've loved every trip back
to visit friends and it's it's a big
place in a complicated place and I know
it well but I don't know well enough did
a lot of corners haven't explored a lot
of people I haven't yet met there that I
could I could focus a bit of energy on
on that city 10 more years I know we'll
see
I feel like a fisherman or a soldier
going off and making the money and then
coming back or maybe not coming back
things are unpredictable sometimes when
I'm off on a long trip my wife and I
talk just about every day one of the
nice things about having an unlocked
cell phone is you get a sim card for
whatever country you're in and outside
the US a lot of the time receiving calls
is free so my wife can call me it
doesn't cost me anything we use skype a
lot skype is a great way to stay in
touch have it on my computer having on
my my iphone and just talk for free all
the time wherever I go it's more
complicated though with a kid uh not
seeing my daughter for two weeks is
really difficult and a trip I took in in
March when I went to Italy I was there
for less than two weeks and when I came
back it was as if she had no idea who I
was she'd been sick a little bit so she
was just not in great shape overall but
when I came back it was just sort of
lack of not lack of recognition but just
a bit freaked out by me but then I just
came back from this two-week trip to to
Central Europe and she's totally cool
with me very comfortably very happy to
see me so I don't know if there's really
a key to it to making it work my wife
now says you know two weeks is the most
i can go away you know after two weeks
maybe I should think twice about coming
back at all uh but yeah there's there's
no key it's just talk make sure
everybody knows what the the ground
rules are having my wife say two weeks
is what you can do makes it so okay yes
now I know two weeks is what I can do
two weeks is the most i can ask for from
her two weeks is the most is the biggest
assignment i can accept from a from a
magazine or a newspaper
hey two weeks that's that's good that's
my limit and if we left it sort of vague
who knows what kind of arguments
intentions would have arisen
with me whenever I can convince my wife
that it's a good idea when when Sasha my
daughter was six weeks old we we all
went off to Italy together we went off
to Venice and Milan for for two weeks I
wouldn't she was just this little nugget
you know fit inside your coat and but I
had a pretty decent time she ate she
slept she stayed warm she didn't cry too
much uh we were in Italy and so people
loved her hola pico Nina oh kk Cara
Bonnie no oh so sweet it was every was
so happy to see her and then in January
when she was a year old this past
January I took her alone to San
Francisco for a week which is much more
complicated endeavor I mean at a year
old all of a sudden you have this
creature who walks who is starting to
talk who eats things but not other
things uh who is developing a sense of
will and a sense of won't and that was
that was tough and that was just me and
her on her own together I was exhausting
i mean just just the physical effort to
keep up with her to take care of her and
to know that at the end of the night the
end of the day there's not another
parent to shift her off to um yeah man
it's just I was asleep at nine thirty
every night because there's no other way
to do it but you know in the end it was
fun I mean I I had a good time she had
an interesting experience who who knows
what she'll remember of it but I like to
think that she's getting accustomed to
the idea and the experience of travel
it's not an unusual thing for her to do
and those were just trips for stories in
the meantime she's been to Taiwan twice
she's been to to Germany she's been to
Minneapolis she's got a well stamped
Passport you know she knows the TSA
drill pretty well at this point you know
I think she's got a bright future ahead
of her as a as a traveler try
writer I don't know I mean she has
trouble counting to three so we may have
to wait a little bit on that